já longe mas essas coisas com confiança
mas aí eu também ia brigando com ações
não chove no agora é se esse foi o
momento do flerte era feriado de
carnaval
eu estava numa praia no litoral de são
paulo quando avistei alguém porque eu me
interessei no nosso livro a nossa
história é fácil de contar não é faz
acontecer no nosso livro a nossa
história
é faz de conta não é faz acontecer
e essa era a pergunta de um milhão de
dólares será que vai dar certo
será que a gente vai ficar junto bem
aqui em santa catarina quando você vai
pra praia você não precisa descer a
serra
mas em são paulo se você for à praia
você necessariamente tem que descer uma
serra e lá em são paulo tem um ditado
que diz que amor de verão não sobe a
serra o ditado bem conhecido lá eu
conheço essa pessoa tal ea gente se
conheceu e quantos e quantos
funcionamento no comércio com essa mesma
pergunta é será que vai dar certo será
que vai acontecer a gente vai ficar
junto
e acho que todo mundo em algum momento
já passou por essa situação ou se não
passou ainda vai passar e bem o feriado
acabou
a gente voltou para são paulo e algumas
semanas depois a gente começou a namorar
apesar da distância porque eu morava na
zona leste no tatuapé
ela morava em carapicuíba e pra quem
conhece são paulo sabe que são pontos
bem distantes um do outro mas a gente
aceitou o desafio e apesar do ditado o
nosso amor sin subiu a serra e dessa
experiência eu decidi escrever uma
música chamada nós pequeno castelo que
essa música que eu toquei um trecho
agora no começo é o nome da música nosso
pequeno castelo se referindo a um
pequeno castelo de areia já que a praia
foi o cenário onde tudo começou e também
fazendo uma metáfora do fato de estar
construindo alguma coisa junto com
alguém que hoje é pequeno mas que pode
se tornar uma história maior né e é
muito legal hoje porque quando eu as
pessoas que gostam essa música me
encontram às vezes no show do teatro
mágico ou elas dizem encontrar contato
comigo pelas redes sociais elas contra o
coxa ganhou sabe que está passando por
uma situação que é exatamente o que sua
letra fala tal é teve outra no outro dia
algumas semanas atrás que conheci um
casal eles me falaram assim poxa com
eles descobriram que eu escrevi essa
música que falam nossa gente adora sua
música ea gente tá pra casar em pouco
tempo ea sua música vai ser o tema do
nosso casamento ou como aconteceu uma
vez que uma menina mandou pra mim uma
foto das alianças
de casamento dela e uma das alianças
dentro da aliança estava gravado me faz
sair em uma outra me faça feliz bem se
podem ter certeza que não existe
absolutamente nada
nada mais incrível para o compositor do
que esse tipo de feedback é algo assim
que cada cada depoimento de seu guarda
com um baita carinho no coração sempre
me emociono
eu acho que esse é um exemplo perfeito
para dizer aquilo que pra mim é a minha
maior meta como compositor quer criar
pontes
eu acho assim nós seres humanos nós
somos muito parecidos a gente a gente
chora gente ea gente se deprime a gente
fica feliz e tudo eu acho que é assim
quando você ouve uma bela canção quando
você tem canções belas não só de amor
mas de amizade ou enfim de política que
seja mais belas canções chegam a gente
sempre que essas canções vêm você vai
encontrar espelho das pessoas as pessoas
vão tomar aquela música elas elas vão se
sentir representada por aquelas músicas
e eu acho que quando o compositor
escreve de forma honesta de forma
visceral e joga aquela pitada mágica de
poesia nas frases eu acho que a chance
de empatia com o público é muito muito
grande sobre compor com por uma tarefa
muito fácil eu digo que é um exercício
de paciência e de muita persistência
cada um tem o seu método eu geralmente
pego meu violão quando tem algum tempo
livre e ficou ali às vezes um tempão
tentam fazer uma seqüência de acordes e
criar alguma melodia porque eu acho
legal
às vezes fica um tempão tal e não sai
nada acaba ficando com raiva ocorre um
lado e falou vou tentar outro dia outra
hora mas às vezes alguma coisa às vezes
alguma coisa lá falou poxa isso aqui
vale a pena ser continuado
e aí eu escolho um tema sobre o qual eu
quero escrever e aí começa a colocar a
letra em cima disso uma única vez na
minha vida eu consegui escrever uma
música e letra é toda num dia é uma
música minha chamada prato do dia a
música pela qual tem um baita carinho
até
hoje e mas isso foi uma coisa assim
aconteceu uma só vez e acho que nunca
vai se repetir porque foi muita sorte
mas na outra ponta da tabela
existirão músicas linhas que levarão
anos para fazer porque às vezes não acho
a palavra certa que eu queria às vezes
não acho a rima que eu mais queria enfim
acaba fechando o caderno falou eu vou
viver isso num outro momento da minha
vida ou não o tempo porque aí não
adianta ficar dando murro em ponta de
faca que não tá não saindo
mas tudo isso eu acho que se a
recompensa de tudo isso é aquele momento
em que eu ponho o ponto final na música
porque naquele momento naquele mesmo
momento que o pintor assina o quadro
porque nessa hora é uma seleção muito
especial porque de repente no mundo
aparecer alguma coisa que não existia e
que se utilizou de você pra acontecer e
pronto tá ali e é uma coisa que vai
poder de repente alcançar o coração das
pessoas tocar as pessoas e eu acho que
isso é um momento muito mágico assim e
sobre ser compositor como profissão bem
é provavelmente se você for só
compositor como eu você vai precisar ter
uma outra atividade porque acho que no
brasil dá para contar nos dedos de uma
mão que quais compositores poderiam se
quisessem viver só de compor né
eu acho que eu já tive banda no passado
hoje não tenho mais
mas eu acho que isso não diminui a
beleza da jornada assim acho que quem
tem paixão por escrever quem tem paixão
por fazer uma letra porque a emocionar
as pessoas eu acho que vai continuar
fazendo isso independente disso ser ou
não a sua atividade principal
eu eu procuro sempre quando vou escrever
uma música
a primeira coisa que eu penso é que eu
quero que a música me emocione porque eu
sei é como falei nem as pessoas são
muito parecidas né então eu como a
música me emocionou
eu tenho certeza que aquilo vai chegar
alguém vai emocionar alguém também então
eu acho que o que é que é claro também
sempre sempre ficou
é sempre sempre torço pra que alguém
veja o potencial de uma música minha e
decida gravar também isso é sempre muito
legal é mais a música pode não ser
gravada pode ser engavetada a música de
repente ela pode ser gravada e pode não
virar um hit
ou pode virar um hit ou pode nunca toca
na rádio enfim
mas eu também acho que isso não tira a
beleza dessa dessa dessa jornada e um
exemplo essa mesma música que eu toquei
no começo né
nosso pequeno castelo eu escrevi essa
música 18 anos atrás essa música foi
gravada em 2012
eu jamais quando escrevi a música
sonharia nem nos meus sonhos mais loucos
claro que eu desejava que acontecesse
mas jamais na verdade foi ali que um dia
lhe é reconhecida que um dia ia ser
gravada mas aconteceu e foi e foi muito
incrível sim porque é que eu acho que a
função da música eu consegui ali essa
função assim é óbvio eu fico muito feliz
quando agravada porque você está usando
a função da tua música o máximo que é
não conectar é conectar as pessoas na
sua capacidade maior é claro porque se
viu sua música gravada
todo artista sonha em sua música a
atingir o maior número de pessoas
possíveis e é muito legal porque isso
cria uma conexão muito grande com as
pessoas e sobre essa conexão da música é
algo bem bacana né sobre essa capacidade
de conexão das músicas é tem uma coisa
que eu sempre gosta de falar que é o
seguinte né eu não sei com vocês mas já
deve ter acontecido
quantas vezes aconteceu comigo eu tenho
grandes amigos hoje que eu fiz a partir
do momento que eu descobri que eles
gostavam tinham gostos musicais
parecidos com os meus
e eu costumo gostar de algumas bandas
desconhecidas então às vezes a pessoa
falar se eu gosto da banda meu deus se
conhece essa banda tipo e ea empatia
imediata é porque você fala nossa
encontrei mais algum cara que gosta da
banda e tenho amigos meus que que a
amizade começou justamente nesse assunto
de música né
eu acho legal isso porque a música ela
não queria só a ponte do artista com as
pessoas
a música ela faz essa conexão e essa
ponte entre as pessoas
eu acho assim ó que não só amizades
podem surgir disso relacionamentos
também você pode conhecer alguém você se
encantar por conta de quantas saber que
ela tem os gostos musicais parecidos com
o seu eu não sei se alguém aqui já
assistiu aquele filme 500 dias com ela
comer pra quem não viu no começo do
filme o rapaz chega no trabalho ele está
no elevador com fone de ouvido ele está
ouvindo uma música do the smiths
bandalhas que eu amo e nisso chegou uma
menina que começou a trabalhar no lugar
há pouco tempo ele não conhecia ainda
ela fica do lado dele e ela percebe que
ele está ouvindo smith pelo som está
vazando do fone ela falando nossa você
gosta de sementes ela falou assim eu
também amo smith se ela começa a
cantarolar um trecho da música dos
limites e naquele momento é perceptível
é como se ela tivesse arrancado o
coração do menino não sei por que ele
fica totalmente sem ar e naquele momento
você vê que ele ficou apaixonado por ela
e esse é o poder da música né
aí com relação a filmes falam de filme
agora é eu sou a pessoa que estou
apaixonado por arte três sites especial
moram no meu coração que é música cinema
e literatura
eu vi e é incrível como você consumir
essas coisas de forma voraz por muitos
anos
isso também ajuda na seu papel como
compositor
eu por exemplo com relação à melodia eu
acho assim pra você compra uma melodia
legal uma melodia bonita eu acho que
necessariamente você tem que ter um baú
de referência de muitos e muito muitas e
muitas milhares de horas de audição de
música você tem que ouvir muita música
porque eu acho que o que você escreve
inédito na verdade é uma só dessas suas
referências então acho que a pessoa tem
que ouvir muita música
no quesito de letras
é claro que você ouve uma música daquele
seu compositor que você tem como ídolo
tal
é bem importante e mas eu acho que nada
no quesito letras é mais importante do
que a leitura eu digo isso porque eu por
exemplo há 18 anos atrás eu consigo eu
consigo ver claramente a diferença do
que compunha a 20 anos atrás por exemplo
de que o compõem hoje há 20 anos atrás
eu lia sei lá no máximo um livro por dia
por por ano
o dia ótima leitura de neve
aí é e mas e e hoje e depois de muitos
anos atrás eu virei um leitor assim mais
assistido então eu sempre coloco uma
bolinha do meu dia ali no final do dia
para ler alguma coisa eu sempre foi uma
meta de um livro por mês ou mais e
conseguir eu consigo ver a diferença
brutal assim do que escrevia
lá atrás o que eu escrevo hoje isso
ajuda muito você cria o repertório de
palavras muito legal e e os livros são
assim eu sempre pego um livro para ler
eu penso nele como um degrau porque eu
sempre vejo assim aqueles meus heróis
compositores lá como se estivesse em
cima de uma escadaria e cada livro que
eu leio é um degrauzinho onde um
passinho para tentar pelo menos chegar
mais próxima daquela daqueles caras lá
em cima daqueles caras que são os meus
heróis sobre isso que eu quero falar um
pouco bem é essas pessoas esses
compositores que eu admiro
são pessoas que eu considero assim como
os superpoderes eu eu eu e eles sabem da
importância da música em tocar as
pessoas e influenciar as pessoas que
eles fazem isso com uma beleza e uma
beleza incrível assim tipo
não foram poucas vezes na minha vida em
alguns momentos onde eu me sentia triste
a gente pra baixo e de repente ouvi uma
música e aquela música dizia algo que
precisava muito vendo aquele momento
nessa hora a impressão que eu tinha é
que é bom que a música era como se fosse
um braço e puxando pra cima assim de um
buraco assim sabe
a música me ajudou demais a música tem
esse poder a música me ajudou diversas
vezes na vida do outro lado da da
história a um momento que você está
muito alegre você conquistar alguma
coisa você tem uma situação incrível e
aí você liga o rádio e no rádio tocando
aquela música que você mais ama
é impressionante como quando você quando
acontece isso como o seu sentimento de
felicidade se potencializa por causa
disso a música é muito poderosa
lennon e mccartney de jager richards
johnny marr morse elton john e bernie
taupin brian wilson
beto guedes alceu valença sacar baleiro
renato russo fernando anitelli são
muitos
esses e tantos outros que eu só tenho a
agradecer o que fizeram e continuam a
fazer diferença na minha vida eu falei
bastante aqui sobre criar pontes aquela
música que eu toquei no começo do toque
é se chama nosso pequeno castel eu fiz
ela bem como eu falei pra vocês no
começo do relacionamento e depois de
alguns anos de casado eu falei poxa já
deu certo né aquela música é uma música
que falava como a dúvida será que vai
acontecer tal eu decidi então fazer uma
música como se fosse uma declaração de
amor e eu falei assim agora vou fazer
uma música uma declaração de amor e
quero que cada frase da música seja uma
declaração de amor
então o que eu é escolhido para encerrar
o tal que com essa música mas antes
quero falar uma coisa eu não sei cantar
é é bom já deixa claro porque é o
seguinte eu não sei eu canto só pra
minha esposa do meu cachorro é eles são
suspeitos mesmo cachorro ta falou nada
mas minha esposa é bem suspeita e
então assim mas eu falei ela quer saber
o que vale assim a ilustrar esse
processo da criação é mostrar mais uma
das manifestações do meu ser
e aqui vai a segunda parte de uma ponte
que completa uma travessia dessa música
se chama vida
você
a esposa
as festas
passou a tomar
só
você
o nome do sócio
então hoje
o sabor
o zabo
atrás
ensina
o jogador